what's up guys code vlogs day 10 on
ancient archer
i've been working on this on my little
laptop so i'm just getting back to my
desktop and synchronizing some changes
wow i have so much to share
this episode and i feel like i'm
definitely going to forget to cover some
of the stuff i want to cover so i'll do
my best here all right i want to point
out the first thing
just
last episode i said hey the renders been
updated
and
oh my goodness this never ends i'm just
going to have to stick with
the old version
version
three 3.3 all right let me just show you
all right
so when we try to use this new version
it works fine when we're in
debug mode let me hit play here
i'll talk about a bunch of stuff that
i've kind of redone and some things that
i've learned
while redoing this because there have
been a few
realizations that make a big difference
going forward all right let me just get
this running here
all
right
oh it's not totally up to date i don't
think no it's missing some of the
updates
all right well we're in debug it renders
fine that's the point here
and we need to
i don't know if it actually got the
changes
let me check something here
yeah
it should have all the new stuff
let me try and release mode here
all right so i put in release mode i'm
going to build this should be identical
to the build on my laptop so it should
work as expected but i'm having a little
odd of these here going
oh there it goes okay it actually built
so
i am gooey is integrated a lot better
i'll talk about that here more in a
second
but i've redid the first person controls
and how they're handled it's a lot
better and as you can see the renderer
it's not perfect you know the lights a
little weird and all and the ground
looks weird that's more more the fault
of my models and the way i've arranged
things than anything else it is working
okay here but
uh let's see if we go to use 4.3 and
turn this to true like it was working
last episode and this is on the lit
vertexes so this is going to be
this dude
oh my goodness yeah we get back to this
i don't know what this is clearly some
of the vertices
are getting snapped to the
zero zero position
i don't know why i don't know what the
heck's going on there
but if we do the same build and debug it
works fine and that's what i'm talking
about in the the last episode i was in
debug
where it works fine but in release it
does not and also for some reason it's
not loading
the other things here when in debug so i
don't know what the heck's going on
there's some definite oddities
going back and forth
and they don't make they don't seem to
make a whole lot of sense
because like uh let's see let's check
the set models
yeah this should set all this stuff
now if from what i understand it is some
return value optimization of some sort
that's happening in release mode
that's causing this it's maybe called
calling a destructor or something
or is uh arranging this data differently
then i'm striding it
and i don't know why i've looked and
look and i i can't figure it out so
we're just going to stick with the old
version it's reliable there's no reason
reason to upgrade if the old one works
fine
and you know the new one works fine
in debug but on release and
that's just so weird
i've looked i don't know if you have any
other ideas other than some return value
optimization thing
because this does go through a model
loader and i looked through all that and
tested some things and i couldn't figure
it out
all right but we're going to move on
from that we're just going to leave it
the old version for now it's fine it's
not hurting anything
and what else to talk about
so the reason it's not rebuilding in in
the debug mode is because
i have something in here that's not
compiling
uh it is
let me find it here
this right here this is not compiling so
yeah we gotta get rid of that
so that's the whole problem here is why
uh the debug one wasn't looking any
different
all right well let's go ahead and
rebuild this
it's a little sample project here
hit play
and it snaps us and it's okay
yeah i gotta move the cam in some weird
directions here
uh accidentally but it's uh that's a
little bit more to sort out
so previously in old versions i had
the callbacks i had it switching between
like a a normal mouse recording and a
first person mouse reporting and the
first person mouse reporting let me find
it down here it's huge
uh
one of these here
this one here it was this whole
custom setup that was built into the
engine
that would do all this stuff but
ultimately this makes this doesn't make
sense to put on the engine side this is
an end user decision
all i really need to do is update the
mouse position
and they can decide so all i did and i
uh
could have realized this a long time ago
but
you know
it is what it is all right so it's it's
just this here this mouse handling
function
so basically i just have some logic to
track the delta
whenever it's disabled and i have some
special settings because
i want to be able to open an inventory
and go out of fpp mode
and that works
uh i can show right here actually and
fpp mode mouse moves things around if i
hit tab
it makes a little sound effect and i'm
now in inventory mode where i can still
walk around but my cursor is now
clicking on the screen
and that re-entering is to snap
everything to the center so it doesn't
fly
because there's something obscure
happening that or not obscure but about
glfw in this handling that i didn't
really get till recently
let me just find it here
so i can explain it all right the cursor
mode in glw they've got hidden disabled
and normal and for disabled they say
that it's like snaps the
it leaves the cursor in the center which
is not true
it doesn't leave it in the center
and i can show you what actually happens
and uh once i realized this i was able
to make my own little
controls without too much thought before
i'm just like i'm just going to copy
paste what works i don't fully
understand it doesn't seem like a snap
into the center it's because it's not
let me just find it here so if we
uncomment this i o stream
and we uncomment this mouse position
now this all this does is just reports
where the mouse is on the screen
and i'm going to show you how this
actually works and with this logic in
mind you can just design your proper
thing all right
so when the mouse is disabled which it
is right now you can see the x position
if i'm going left go way negative and
just it just keeps going negative it's
in the negative twenty thousand negative
thirty thousand so it doesn't reset to
zero you just have to track the delta
and the in the last x since you got the
delta and apply that
so it wasn't too bad to reason about
once i figured out that this is how it
works it just keeps going
and this is a thing you notice on a lot
of
a lot of applications whenever you click
like a
and i've noticed on blunder whenever you
click some scrollable thing it disables
your mouse while you're scrolling it so
that you can just keep going with the
slider scroll even off your screen if
it's huge
you see that a lot of apps so that's how
they do it it's pretty cool
and i didn't really realize how it
worked until i started to dig in and
rewrite it because previously i was just
using the function from learn opengl
which is a fine function but this one
makes a lot more sense for me going
forward because
this is literally all the engine does is
updates the position
however the end user wants to handle it
that's fine we don't need to have that
in the engine it's just uh
it's a yagny thing you ain't gonna need
it right
because
the engine doesn't need it for any
reason end users
could need it for the games they want
but you know they're designing the game
they get to decide that
so a lot of a lot of great learning
experiences here
and i'm pretty sure there's something
else i wanted to show i just got to
think of it
what was it
well i started redoing not redoing just
i kind of reorganized the example
project to make a little more sense it
just takes
the ancient archer header and does an
instance and it well cause it calls it
an instance so these are the two globals
you got a game
and instance now ancient archer is like
the media control stuff
handles all that in the game is just
going to handle all the logic so
i've got it to run through a setup
ancient arch is going to run any of the
game updates and the game tear down i
don't really use the dare down yet but
it says shutdown function essentially
but since it automatically adds the my
game update we can take this game
and have an update here in just anything
we put in this function
it's always going to work
and be in that main update
so there you go you can see the main
character update it's basically
processing the move and also cut back a
few other functions i guess it's the
last thing i'm going to talk about is
getting a little long
but there were a bunch of
functions
that i determined weren't all that
necessary sure there's plenty of plenty
more but
cursors see this mouse stuff these are
all getting cut because that's
end user decision not something that
needs to be in the engine
and this gui is going away because i am
implementing
i am gooey
in a pretty fully functional way i guess
i can show that that'll be the last
thing there might be more stuff i've
been working on this a lot in the last
two days
but yeah we want to get rid of this ue
and we want to
use the imgui now the imgui you might
have noticed there's no functions in
here for it
actually there is one
and because we're just going to put it
on the updates the imgui update now i
have an imgui class
and i'm not going to pretend that this
is the best way to do it this is a hack
job
i am gui class we can initialize it with
our glfw window for opengl and if i add
vulcan or whatever i can add a function
for that too
it's got just like the recommended imue
stuff a shutdown a new frame and a
render and you're supposed to do new
frame update render as you go so this
will do the new frame and the render but
we need to do the update somewhere else
because if i just hard code in here
it's going to get uh
you basically have to go edit the engine
class so i wanted to do in a way where
you don't have to edit the engine class
to do your own gui and the way we do we
do that is we have these functional
loops
the functional base
so
we have this add to imgui update it
takes a function
and you basically just put your imgue
update in that in a way to remove it of
course
and the actual
unordered map of all of them
so what you end up doing
is
here we go
you basically just do this you just take
your instance
that you initialized
and uh
add i'm gooey update and you basically
can copy paste any imgui code
into this update and it's gonna it
already does the new frame and render
part it just needs the update in the
center
so i can show you that too we're
bouncing around all over the place at
this point
but
hey we're digging in we're digging in
so yeah there's an update here
on ancient archer that runs every time
and it goes through all the logic it
needs to go through
and then there's a render
and on the render
this is where all the i am gooey stuff
happens now this might not be correct
maybe i should have like
some of this stuff in the update and
only the render here or something but
whatever it's fine for now it's going to
be the last thing that's drawn anyway
so yeah here it is there's the imgui new
frame there's the render those are
always the same but whatever you add to
the update that's what actually updates
so that gives the end user like in this
example project the ability to just
have their own imgui function add to it
you can remove it if you want
and you can set your variables with it
so currently it's just a demo right now
but i could tie any of the stuff to the
rest of the game which i plan on doing
making a better example of it
alright well this has been a lengthy one
there's probably more
but uh
yeah i think this
version's getting close to coming out i
really want to get to animations but i
just had to sort out a few other loose
ends that were bothering me and i think
once we're done with that we're
we're on to the next now i might just
i gotta think about it i'm gonna take a
day or two i usually like to try to get
a release out on friday if i can
so i got a couple more days i'll see if
about getting animations in if it
happens easily
i'll put it in version six if it doesn't
happen easily i'll push it back to
version seven i'll release version six
kind of ready to go here
another thing i wanted to do was get rid
of this example project and make it its
own repo
that like sub modules in this project
and just make only the core tests come
with aaa engine because you can run
these
okay i crashed something
one of these tests just see tests have
been initialized correctly
like like so
and the other test just make sure that
it returns negative four if you don't
initialize it
and we'll be adding more tests but
they're kind of hard to add without
we need some sort of like pop-up to
question the user like hey do you see
this window type of thing
and i could probably do that with i am
gooey pretty quickly
but that's kind of going on the back
burner
um
that's just uh for the future at some
point well that's gonna do it for this
episode
hope you enjoyed
see you guys next time
[Music]
you